okay first up here is the two-term mayor
of Chicago and former White House chief
of staff he's done it all Mayor Rahm
Emanuel of Chicago
[Applause]
welcome mr. mayor and I guess I won't be
able to call you that much longer you
are not running for a third term as the
mayor of Chicago right when when is your
term end May 20th you're counting the
day so I bet o'clock yeah not that I
know you deserve a break yeah I mean
you've been in the battle since the
begum and you're in the Clinton White
House chief of staff for Obama that's a
killer job you think you can you tell me
but you must be tired and you earned a
break where one serious thing though as
a son and the grandson of an immigrant
you know serve two presidents Congress
mayor the city that welcomed my grant my
grandfather mm-hmm greatest city
greatest country in the world can't be
anywhere else in the world that you can
be the son of an immigrant and become
the mayor of the city that your friend
[Music]
who's here to argue with that we can
find some but so what is your take on
the national emergency what what should
be the strategy you or if you're in the
White House as you were with Obama you
would have to come up with a strategy to
combat this well first of all no because
our president wouldn't do this no no I
know right so here's the first and
formost and I think that people got it
you have a foe constitutional crisis to
basically cover up a real campaign
crisis this is all about the campaign
sure some pledge you made right and so
what you have now and I think that the
direct approach and the right thing to
do you want to stop drugs you want to
start products no declare a national
emergency declared national emergency on
opiates yeah
opiates are killing people they're
manufactured here so that's what we
should be playing oh geez we thought
okay so now but I mean and then we
thing is and I think what we have to do
is actually the whole strategy is and
there's an opening here and that is when
you have a pincer and you have to create
a pincer campaign against Trump and the
base of the Republican Party because
they're not for this and now for the
first time remember his mace is not for
this no because the Coulter no there's
more than just her I'm talking about
people that in the members of the House
and Senate and they're and the true
people that believe in that if you give
the president they know Democrats are
gonna one day get back there if you
start to lower the bar what becomes a
national emergency you're giving it
ready the chief of staff and so I would
drive a wedge between the right now the
only thing holding up the president is
the fact that he's cowed the entire
Republicans right and start driving that
wedge there to weaken him going into 20
that's what the Democrats need a wedge
driver like you you know some other
adjectives have been used to dispel we
like that so that's what you want the
strategy yeah I know I think the biggest
thing you want divided base okay
president going into now twenty now I'm
a big fan of Nancy Pelosi
I'm so glad when everyone was whispering
in my ear oh they need new leadership
you should know I said no and it's it we
agreed on that yes and she's doing
invasive and she proves yes this is why
you don't need a rookie sitting across
from the right panel
Donald Speaker Seth Moulton would not
have done okay so but she said today I
think it was today these days goodbye so
quickly was sometimes you wanted to go
but yeah she she floated the idea out
there if it was a different president
maybe we would declare a national
emergency on guns I don't think this is
good politics
no no for the next election a lot of
people just vote on guns and it sounds
like oh the Democrats are licking their
chops to declare in a national emergency
on guns and and yeah go ahead I was
gonna say I was showing restraint it's a
rhino or me but I know but not it may be
a crisis guns but it's not a national
emergency we can't be as bad as them
right a hundred I think that the one
thing you don't want to mimic their
politics and there are times in fact you
want to show the strength but on this
case I would not say we're gonna declare
this emergency that emergency people
don't like this they're not for what's
going on here they'll see through it
actually
confidence in the American people
they'll see this for what it is and what
it and they'll reject it and the good
idea is not to lower he wants you on
certain cases to actually mimic what
he's doing because then there's a
difference than nothing that's not where
you want to go against him so how do we
break this cycle between the two parties
that we've been in for such a long time
I mean they go back to Bork and then
Clinton was impeached for really what we
don't think he should have been
impeached for and they know better and
then they think bush was handled very
unfairly and Obama of course was handled
unfairly and they wouldn't even admit
you get to a point where Mitch McConnell
says we're not even gonna consider
everything we're gonna block everything
and if we do get rid of Trump those
people who are supporters are not gonna
go away they're just gonna want revenge
you're a mayor you break cycles and
things how do you break this cycle
well there is an i well there's a couple
things I'm I think that actually were I
actually think what Donald Trump had
from an optimist is actually reignited a
civic pride and civic engagement in the
country that we haven't seen his legacy
will be people are getting involved in a
level in a level we could not do before
the second thing and this is what I
would call for the country I mean I'm
not running and don't want to run we
need national service again to reignite
the threads that unite us as citizens in
this country and people committing again
to serve to the country I actually think
the way you don't do this is retribution
I actually think that the American
people especially the young want to be
lifted up to higher ideals and I think
that's a place to go for the party and I
think that one of our nominees will
actually touch that flame and ignite it
for in the way the Kennedy did and who
do you think that nominee will be that's
what the voters will pick and you know
what I do know about campaigns having
gone six for six they reveal character
had to get that in they review okay they
reveal character people will lift the
hood kick the tires change it look at
the oil and we will find people forget
this both Barack Obama President Clinton
two people I work for we're not seen as
the frontrunners they emerge as a
front-runner and they will be able to
show they can take a punch and deliver a
punch they'll be able to raise the
country to the level and then be go
mano-a-mano against
speaking of lifts and you can't see it
on paper you can't see it on paper it
will happen and that person will emerge
in the debates you tow through the
campaign see do the campaign they'll do
things and you'll start to see Ronald
Reagan in his moment I paid for this
microphone it became a moment that
captured his character and that will
there will be that moment okay what do
you think the governor of Virginia
should do well well I mean I'm gonna say
here's what I think and I know you seem
nervous about no I don't I don't buy
that he that's not his photo I think
that is his photo yes okay Israeli and
it's wrong we all agree on that
okay now what I think though is that
what I do know in reading a lot of
history you take Barack Obama he wasn't
for gay marriage at first well he
integrated the Armed Forces so gay and
lesbians to serve the country they love
and not be judged by the person they
love President Lincoln didn't go fight
the war to end slavery it was for the
Union came to be the great Emancipator I
think worth them in the part of civil
rights part of any change his maturity
and evolution he is now going to be the
greatest fighter for civil rights
because he has something to prove and he
was Eric there so my button I don't know
where this notion is and I I really so
and he was a pretty good one which is
why 58% of african-americans in Virginia
want him to stay on the job and because
they also got health care he got
Medicare through well my point is but on
all these things the notion that you
disagree with somebody the answer is
you're fired
the fact is he has evolved and he has
something now if you want somebody
there's nothing like a convert he is
gonna have a zealot tree to prove
something because he has the campaign of
his reputation and to my view is he has
something and you can't this notion
Virginia escape history no you learn
from history you don't escape history
and then it teaches you what to do right
in the future so might be that's how you
go
so I saw today you in the city of
Chicago sent a letter to Jeff Bezos over
at Amazon nothing salacious about your
email yeah or pictures and you were
trying to lure Amazon to Chicago because
they pulled out of New York what do you
think about that what do you think about
New York losing that and where Amazon
should go obviously you want them in
your city well I mean here's what first
of all for five consecutive years
Chicago is the number one city in
America for corporate relocations every
year five straight why are we bribing
corporations if that was the issue in
New York do we really have to do well
it's not the issue well here's a that's
a fair question and my own view take a
look at New York you look at it what
they should have said look fix the
subway near that where we're gonna go
and everybody will gain they would have
got a ticker tape parade and that is
same dollars but go to actually because
of what the condition of the subway
system in New York they would have been
seen as actually coming in as a good
neighbor and my view is there's a lot of
economic growth that you can create that
there's multiple winners and it's a
win-win situation rather than as you say
whether it's enticing or financial I
think Chicago has a lot to offer and the
number one thing it has to offer the
best educated workforce in the United
States of America spoken like the still
mayor of Chicago you've earned your
vacation
[Applause]
you